If you're like, I wanna fucking start a business,
the only thing that's holding me back is I don't know what to do.
And I kinda want somebody to hold my fucking hand.
I'll hold your fucking hand.
So let's go. Last summer I got accepted into this, like,
program with a small business association.
And it helped kind of literally
hold my hand and walk me through the process of starting an LLC
so that I could start earning income as a side hustle and grow that
and benefit from all the tax breaks that you get as a business owner.
And it just allowed me to earn money
in ways that I could work around my schedule
for my children. And I've been very successful at that
and I've been very happy with what I've done.
And a lot of women have reached out to me and said,
I wanna leave too. I need.
I need to figure out how I can get my finances in order.
And I have started a little challenge.
It's a 30 day challenge. The
you know where to sign up.
And basically I have kind of
taken everything I Learned from the Small Business Association
and what I've done, all the like,
different little businesses and side hustles that I've done.
I partnered with my friend who owns a business.
She runs a very successful advertising company.
So over 30 days, you will learn how to start your own business.
Like you Will start an LLC.
One of the lessons that we will teach you
is how to go to your secretary of state website,
find LLC. This is not how to become an MLM or master resale rights.
We're not gonna like.
This isn't like somebody else's course that we're just, like,
teaching you. This is real shit.
There's gonna be a live seminar every week.
So for 30 days you're gonna get a 20 minute recorded lesson.
Either me, myself or Nikki is gonna be, like,
teaching you. That day.
There'll be, like,
a little bit of homework for you to do.
And what we're trying to do
is get you into the habit of working on your business
every single day. And when you're starting up a business,
there really is, you know,
some time that you have to put into it.
And by the end of this 30 days,
you're gonna be very confident in the skills that you have
in the business, that you have,
the offerings that your business provides,
and least have all the skills to start making sales.
The rest is up to you. So if that sounds interesting to you,
for 30 days, you'll be hearing from me,
seeing me. And then every week,
once a week, there will be a live session.
If you can't attend the live session,
it'll be recorded and you'll get it in your email.
So I really, really,
genuinely wanna help women get on their feet.
And Take their power back.
So if that sounds good to you.
The link to enroll. You can either DM me or find the link.
Um. I love you,
and I wish you all the most.